if you're trying to pick what Market
you're going to go in I talk about this
in my book 100 offers there's four
things I want to look at number one are
they in pain am I actually solving a
problem for someone number two are they
easy to find because I can't find them I
can't sell them number three do they
have the money to spend in order to buy
my thing because if I'm trying to sell
to broke people it's probably not going
to be a good idea number four are they
growing I don't want to be selling their
newspapers I want to be selling to
something like old people there's more
of them every single day that are
retiring so I want to go where the wins
are if I have a market that checks all
four of those boxes then I know I'm at
least in a good opportunity